The next location on our list, I have never seen anything like this.
It is something out of a novel or a film.
What I'm about to show you will blow your mind.
The next location and probably the most interesting place on this list...
...is the world's strongest whirlpool.
Located in the Nordland, this is the strongest tidal current in the entire world.
These whirlpools were so large that they could swallow boats.
If we were to get close enough to the whirlpool,...
...you could actually feel it dragging the boat into it.
Up to 400 million tons of seawater forced their way...
...through a three-kilometer long and only 150-meter wide strait...
...every six hours with the tides.
Water speeds reach 37 kilometers per hour at the peak of the whirlpool.
But no really, I've never seen currents this fast.
And there's actually whirlpools, like when you flush a toilet,...
...that's what we have except times a thousand.
So, let's go!
And no poop.
The whirlpools themselves are huge.
Some can be up to ten meters in diameter...
...and reach five meters deep in the heart of the vortex.
Five meters deep!
Now, on the day that I was there, they were not nearly that big...
...but I couldn't even imagine seeing a whirlpool that big and that powerful...
...because they do get that big.